para los sindicatos el objetivo de este
día era un martes en negro un día en que
todo el país fuera bloqueado con no
huelgas y manifestaciones Puede que no
haya habido un bloqueo completo del país
pero lo cierto Es que Francia sí estuvo
a media marcha a lo largo de todo este
día con huelgas generalizadas en el
sector de la educación de los
transportes especialmente el transporte
público en ciudades Como por ejemplo
aquí en París así como en el transporte
ferroviario que de hecho el tráfico de
los trenes estará perturbado hasta este
próximo jueves también huelgas en las
refinerías la mayoría de las refinerías
del país que suspendieron todas sus
actividades a lo largo de este día ahora
lo cierto Es que aquí en París al menos
700,000 personas salieron a manifestar
eso es casi el doble en realidad de lo
que sucedió hace 15 días en la última
manifestación y en todo el país también
fue una mayor participación falta
saberes Entonces cuál va a ser el efecto
de todas estas manifestaciones en la
posición del gobierno Lo cierto es que
entre los manifestantes encontramos
algunos que todavía creen que hay
esperanza de que el gobierno retire este
proyecto de ley de reforma pensional de
pasar la edad de jubilación de 62 a 64
años Aunque hay algunos que creen que ya
no hay manera de dar marcha atrás pero
todavía pueden hacerse algunas mejorías
En todo caso al texto de ley y mientras
la gente está manifestando en todo el
país al mismo tiempo el senado continúa
el examen de la proyecto de ley y se
espera ya para el 15 de marzo que haya
una comisión paritaria siete diputados
siete senadores que deben reunirse para
ya dar una versión final de este texto
que luego volverá a ser votado por ambas
cámaras para finales de este mes